when I when I when I came on YouTube it
was like I was about 23 or some [ __ ]
so I usm years under my belt and I
decided to come here and then every time
I met somebody on YouTube I [ __ ]
hated them I was like [ __ ] these people
like they're just like what's the word
I'm looking for [ __ ] losers it's like
I just [ __ ] ate it and but there was
a few people that I clicked with it was
the JK people who I still work with
today and you guys yeah and I was like
oh these are just normal human beings
because a lot of the youtubers at the
time they just weren't they just didn't
know how to interact with people felt
like I felt like everything was the you
know either their impersonation of other
youtubers or they're so uncomfortable in
their own shoes when there are other
real other youtubers that it makes it
awkward but the thing is when we met
David right yeah I think you were one of
the most genuine people we met and it
just clicked our comedy clicked together
yeah like I could sell off I was a
mutual respect because not only this
attitudes of the other youtubers their
content I was just like a lot of them I
just was like this is yeah like you know
you know this is just not necessarily up
to par with what we want to do ya see
ourselves doing but when we saw your
stuff it was like okay this guy gets it
he has a sense of calm and he up the
production right early on yeah you're
really trying to shoot high quality
stuff and then any time you come do
stuff with us you would kill it so I was
like I think I feel like we always
gravitated towards the real ones in
YouTube even if it's only five you know
we're always gonna find those guys you
know the funny thing is too cuz you know
when I when people ask me to work on
projects if I don't really know them
like I look at it now think about it you
did I mean but if you guys let's do it
we put you in the most stereotypical
role I saw the video again because it
was two of them right yeah but they're
still funny till this one funny as [ __ ]
no I mean this is this is a humble brag
but our content someone tweeted of it
ages it ages better
ages well and then when it first comes
out like when it's I don't know I mean
we edit we shoot it so by the time it
comes out we're just like huh
yeah yeah but like a year later you go
watching like wow this was really rich
man and I don't watch it I don't tend to
watch our content a lot yeah it's
usually like I'm just like right let's
get better with next one on to the next
one how can we do better in the next one
but the times that I do take a break and
actually go back and watch stuff Davis
clips are [ __ ] hilarious every
[ __ ] time I can't stop the [ __ ]
episode we have so many bloopers - god
yeah but we don't even put those out yet
but we need to get the whole the [ __ ]
the one with the the lean and lean on
one dude like I was leaning Leon goes to
the chiropractor the smallest [ __ ] dude
the [ __ ] x-ray draw that was that was
during the time though I felt like I
think for all of us - when we talk about
this a lot where it was really fun
always it was funny with you yeah yeah
it was super exciting and I think like
at that time
everybody's content was so different and
I got this sample a lot of different
stuff and now every time I go on to a
channel it's like I've seen this already
like I've seen this styled this the way
that you're speaking the way it's set up
it's somebody else's [ __ ]
so I like when I watched you - now I'll
be I get very I want say sad but it's
hard for me to find content I [ __ ] with
mm-hmm
yeah other day like it's I guess like if
we're something we're all 30 yeah yeah I
think like the 20s and up kind of just
adapted this like oh let's do it works
yeah it's not necessarily like oh let's
try to find something that's different
it's just oh let's do what works yeah I
remember even talking to a younger
person and them telling us like why
don't y'all just do reaction videos I'm
like oh you know our channel doesn't
mean as much views as it used to
whatever well I should just do reaction
videos I'm like but that's not what we
do yeah yeah yeah so it's like they
don't even process the fact that oh
you're trying to do something just do
something that's popular and
it'll get views I was the big deal but
that's the best the thing about that too
is though there's a reason why a lot of
these younger people who are on media
the only last three or four years
because after a while you can only steal
so [ __ ] much there's everybody's seen
all your tricks so when it comes time
for people to innovate and they got to
do new [ __ ] they're fresh out right and
I think for us like we've been able to
expand outside of just YouTube because
of all the the skills that we developed
yeah right and it's you know to their
credit like I'll catch myself sometimes
too like for example like reaction
videos right it's funny that you mention
that because there was a point where I
was like you should just do reaction to
it
do it throw some [ __ ] pies in your
face prank people do some [ __ ]
and because it does it does start to hit
you a little bit yeah it makes you feel
the way when you put out something that
you work hard on and it doesn't get as
much as it should as you think it should
you're just like what am I doing this
for
cuz at the end of the day I even if it
wasn't for the money I at least was
doing it for the people's reaction and I
love that I got yeah now I'm not I'm
barely getting that and the money still
sucks you kind of question yourself but
then that's got a dig deeper and be like
what is this r1 my one day hope that 10
years from now someone's gonna watch
this and hopefully it makes them do
something great I really do believe that
a lot of the stuff that you guys were
doing was way before its time like you
guys were innovators right so a lot of
the [ __ ] that I see now and I'm like
that's some old-ass dorm paper [ __ ] you
know what I mean but let me we say it
[Laughter]
like what we wanted to do in a way it
was our mission without even knowing
that's what we were doing yeah cuz we
always used to stress they're like yeah
we just do it ourselves like we don't
have to wait on nobody and we would say
it to our fans not knowing that oh
they're hearing it rob least there's
people out there watching now who's
doing Instagram and stuff now that
probably heard that I was like shoo okay
and don't get it twisted we still want
to be the greatest [ __ ] comedy group
out here but at the same time to inspire
others I mean that's a make like I'm
amazing fence
yeah that's an amazing feat like I
wanted to see people I want to see what
ever genre we're in whatever our craft
is comedy so I want to elevate that as
much as we can some [ __ ] though it's
like sometimes I'll go out to these
shows and I see you know I'll meet a
couple of like newer youtubers or media
people right yeah and they're like yo
man you inspired me when I was younger
I'm like cool let me get a thousand
dollars in money son of a [ __ ]
something dude I'm over here dying we're
trying to create a good art and [ __ ] you
have your watered-down version of my
[ __ ] and it's so much better yeah but
that just goes to show like also to in
this platform you really do have to
learn how to evolve because I know other
people who put their heart into their
art but they just didn't evolve with the
times and then they're wondering like
like for example this is the best
example I'll game out its YouTube
musicians when YouTube first started
anybody could have been a musician yeah
you don't mess you go back to some of
these covers that they're doing they are
arguably terrible singers but they have
two million three to ten million views
and so they expected that type of
success but guess what happens you
singing on a platform out without a NRS
without all this other [ __ ] inspired
other people to do it that were way
better than you know and so there was
real musicians that came out and now
they're trying to do their same [ __ ]
and they're like well I'm not getting
abused it's cuz you're actually finding
out you were actually weren't that good
yeah competition is stepped up yes is
where you like once the industry found
out this is what the power of YouTube or
the power of social media can do
everyone's gonna look Turner I hear
you're gonna get better people so it's
up to you whether you want to get better
mmm-hmm and push yourself or you're just
gonna stay there and just you know
you're gonna fall by the wayside
yeah competition is fierce now yeah you
know like music I've seen like some of
these cats were damn like for example
think about this Justin Bieber was a
youtuber man yeah crazy [ __ ] YouTube
crazy [ __ ] uh Issa Rae Donald Glover
Donald Glover [ __ ] like these people
you know they they made it to the top
man I'd issa race trajectory's [ __ ]
crazy like you talk about can I get a
thousand dollars
remember that one time we met each other
ISA ad [ __ ] in that sandwich shop my
guys remember that day like it was
yesterday and I nobody should have
[ __ ] planted my seed on you like you
were [ __ ] Oprah dude I should I
should have done something but just
watching so she's uh she's amazing man
like just watching how successful she is
and I'll be it like I gotta say man
she's everything she has she deserves to
she was one of those people that I saw
that I was really really rooting for and
then when she popped off I was like yeah
no [ __ ] right just like you very
authentic saying like she's been the
same since we've met it you know I'm
saying you know the relationship we've
had with it like she's just she popped
off around the same time we started
right no awkward black girl I remember I
guess we were two years later we were
already kind of like deep into YouTube
were maybe two hundred thousand subs
dropping videos and then she she kind of
she we just are hearing about this
awkward black girl thing one of the guys
in the group can yeah brought it to us
and yeah at the time I think she was
getting like a hundred thousand views on
each episode and then we just kind of
like yeah we hit her up too and and she
ended up she said she liked our videos
as well and then we just kind of kept
the relationship that's why you
sometimes it's good to be I guess I
don't know I can't find the proper word
but to approach someone first because I
you know a lot of times I feel like we
all like oh I'm not gonna say nothing
cuz say some to me or counter in a way
but it's just like that it was just no
humidity
it was just like yo we're fans and then
it ended up being she was fans and I
felt like that was one of the best
things we've ever done relationship is
just being open and free just being able
to say we're fans not even known if she
knew us or not yeah but just showing her
love and then yeah I just feel like it
was a good lesson to carry on I always
like show loved II felt like every
industry is like that yeah people will
sit back and just watch you in knowing
they could kind of help they could
probably help your situation but like
you I mean we're talking more if you
don't ask for something you won't
necessarily know what you can get not
even ask but just just like the people
in your industry like sometimes you know
I'm sure if you go to some like shoppers
industry and it's like you know
Ralph's in there
food for less I feel like they're not
talking to each other either they
probably got their arms molded but you
know I feel like with us we're able to
work together we can do videos together
we can do we can you know and away from
that we just need to appreciate each
other more you know yeah yeah show love
towards other you don't love towards
other creators it's not oh wait it's not
even a competition honestly we're not
competing you get a lot of the a lot of
successful youtubers definitely they do
they cross platforms a lot right so they
work with other people and they try to
spread out that way
I definitely did not do that I was like
I [ __ ] hate you get the [ __ ] away
from me you know I mean but they like it
was one of those things that I think was
hard for me like I just like like a you
know we mentioned this I just didn't
[ __ ] with their [ __ ] yeah so it was hard
but if I did [ __ ] with them I definitely
would reach out yeah I would let's let's
work on something together or I'll just
be in something that you do right for
example somebody somebody else that did
really great was [ __ ] batch yeah yeah
because I remember well first of all I'm
gonna tell you how this [ __ ]
story batch I'm pretty sure you're not
listening this because you're way above
me now you piece of [ __ ] but that she
was sucking funny so when I first met
him what's the name uh that's good yeah
he was supposed to be in my sketch and
he said yo there's his young cat named
batch Andrew bachelor you should work
with him and so he would replace that
role for for Wes and so when I was
working on and with this small little
sketch and it was with my buddy Josh me
and Josh looked each other light and
this [ __ ] way better than us
he's a great actor yeah I was like damn
he's [ __ ] good dude like and I
remember telling Josh I was like this
dude is gonna be some [ __ ] big [ __ ]
out here yeah because he was I could
tell he was just hustling and working
hard he didn't give up [ __ ] yeah right
and then when we started working
together I was so surprised how he
decided he'd started to develop his own
group and his network because he started
popping off on the vine thing and so we
did this sketch I remember even before
that he did something with sha now he
was on YouTube made him he was on
YouTube heavy my accused dropping skits
but and the quality was actually high
for that time but I'm saying I think it
was like he did something with Shaq like
a comedy series it was the same
all those people Oh YouTube was giving
money to all these celebrities to start
sharing right I thought this fool was
dealing drugs or something I was like
where the [ __ ] are you getting money for
this you're a nobody like there's no
where the [ __ ] is this money I thought
yeah I bet you do what the shitty thing
is is like with people this is the hater
of me I'm like with somebody I really
like to and I'm like god I'm trying to
find something wrong about you is
matches that [ __ ] is [ __ ] the size of
this mic yeah looking for something
wrong cuz it do was super nice super
humble and you know I'm pretty sure he
has his flaws I don't know what they are
yet but yeah one one thing though I will
say about this [ __ ] lied to me
about his age when I first met him so
when I first met him he told me that he
was like 3 or 4 years younger than me
right and then lo and behold I forgot
what we were looking at but he was on a
pitch deck that I was on and his age
popped up and he's like my age I was
like you stupid son of a [ __ ] so he did
the LA thing when he first moved right
about his age and I was like oh [ __ ]
would you do that that boat I can't jump
somebody told me to do that I think my
ex told me to do that she was like you
guys should say you're young I know I'm
good I see why people do it because I
mean I guess it appeals to younger
people and keep it I want my I want
people who need to know me know me like
yeah I don't need to appeal to people
who are my my in my category I
understand when a girl does it just
because of a societal pressure like once
you reach a certain age or too old or
whatever type of [ __ ] even the whole
thing is just like embrace the age man
like holidays looking good to me all
that matters is your content yeah like
are you good at your craft like can you
are you trying to push the limits are
you trying to get better like that's
alright I guess that one I appreciate
you more yeah like I said when people
don't understand it they're gonna age
like you know that shit's inevitable
right yeah like that's that's a [ __ ]
science thing yeah
to age people died at 20 people die
every day every year you should be like
man I'm getting old and I'm still
[ __ ] here you know cuz because I mean
how hard is it for us to see like a lady
out in [ __ ] like Fairfax without her
lips done her [ __ ] cheeks no Botox
and I'm like [ __ ] that I don't even
remember what a normal human being looks
like anymore like what's that like what
the [ __ ] is with this constant where
beauty is a set certain way they look
like aliens that I would still [ __ ] yeah
but I see it a lot like you know
especially with some of my like my
friends even like I specifically here in
LA yeah I think because when we're on
social media all we can think about is
how we look and we are perceived man
others I think I think even nowadays I
was thinking my dad like it's just even
in music you gotta be I feel like you
have to be beautiful to sell hmm I feel
like you either you beautiful or you
gotta like have the flyest like that's
how you gotta be free weirdest weirdest
[ __ ] plan you gotta have you gotta be
the lad or something you can't just be a
regular guy that's Malone ugly type of
[ __ ] like the cutest person is like them
there's no in-between right now is just
like people just want to see the best of
the best and I feel like they got mad
options on on and on the gram to look at
it because you're doing music right now
yeah yeah so what made you I mean you
guys have always been doing me right
right you actually doing music music now
I guess you just call it that because
anything it's not it's not based on the
comedy album right yeah it's it's a
discovering process every freaking day
man and I try not to take it sick I was
even listening we were listening to
y'all on the way here and I was just
like I don't want it I don't wanna take
myself to see I heard Timothy say
something about like you know just like
he just likes things where people just
naturally themselves it's not taking it
too seriously I don't want to go home
I'm studying music like I actually love
to do it and just like to create but
it's a learning process man every day
like every time I work with so another
artist I'm like damn I got a long way to
go yep like the other day this guy came
through and his voice is just like he
was I don't even know I explained it but
his his singing voice was so on top yeah
and I was just like damn I know it took
him a while to find that because it's
like it's it was so
you need to him know